In France, most French trains are at a standstill,...
...schools across the country shut down...
...and the Eiffel Tower warned visitors to stay away,...
...as unions held nationwide strikes and protests...
...over the government's plan...
...to overhaul the retirement system.
At least 58 migrants trying to reach Europe from West Africa died,...
...as their makeshift boat capsized off the coast of Mauritania.
Dozens of survivors managed to swim to shore.
A 23-year-old rape victim was set ablaze by a gang of men,...
...including the alleged rapist,...
...as she made her way to court in northern India,...
...stirring public outrage and shame...
...over the scourge of crimes against women.
Violence in Mozambique's Cabo Delgado...
...is forcing scores of people from their homes,...
...destroying villages and making it difficult for families...
...to recover from Cyclone Kenneth,...
...which hit the area in April 2019.
Finally from Nigeria, an oil pipeline explosion...
...is thought to have killed one person and injured another.
There has been no official statement on the cause of the explosion.